Star Wars fans Rejoice The Witches of
dathomir have made their long-awaited
live-action debut first introduced in
the now Legends novel The courtship of
Princess Leia The Witches eventually saw
their entrance into Canon territory when
they appeared in Dave filoni's Star Wars
the Clone Wars in the Animated Series
the daughters of dathomir also called
the night sisters amazed and baffled
audiences by bathing in Dark Side energy
and wielding ancient magic powers The
Witches certainly weren't Jedi but they
didn't fully align with Sith beliefs
either now the witches and their Crimson
robes have returned in League with grand
Admiral thrawn no less in the latest
episode of Ahsoka the magic wielders are
waiting on paridia for Morgan elsbeth to
arrive with her retinue there are three
witches and Star Wars fans may want to
know who the actors are bringing these
mysterious characters to life
bringing to life the great mother
actropaw is none other than Gerald
Prescott without her Scarlet robes and
Eerie makeup long time walking dead fans
probably recognize this actor Prescott
was one of the core characters in The
Show's first season she portrayed Jackie
one of the First characters who stood up
to Carol's abusive husband Ed Jackie
perished at the end of the season when
she decided to remain behind at the CDC
which was time to explode in recent
years Prescott has taken prominent
recurring roles in shows like all the
queen's men and Swamp Thing the latter
wasn't her only DC project as she also
was in an episode of Batwoman prior to
that she played in episodes of Shameless
Scandal and NCIS Los Angeles in
she also guest starred in five episodes
on Showtime's hit series Ray Donovan
while Ahsoka may be the actor's first
time in a galaxy far far away she is
obviously no Padawan when it comes to
performing
Jane Edwina Seymour portrays the keysis
the death of mirian witch who informs
Morgan elsbeth of thrawn's incoming
arrival the actor was very thrilled to
join the Star Wars Universe having
frequently expressed her excitement on
her social media before Ahsoka debuted
writing excited for this to go to Air
and very grateful to be a part of this
Star Wars series I loved working on it
in so many ways
Seymour is no stranger to the world of
sci-fi having recently appeared in two
episodes of Star Trek Picard as the Borg
Queen before that Seymour took part more
grounded dramas such as Nova Vida
playing Dr Perkins and starring
alongside names like Titus Welliver and
Dean Norris eagle-eyed fans of Netflix's
you may also recognize her as she played
a hilariously upbeat and sort of
inappropriate Library goer who
compliments Joe Goldberg's child just a
bit too much thankfully she only
appeared in a single episode in the
show's third season any longer and she
may have had to endure Joe's Wrath
portraying clotho who appears to be the
leading great mother is video game
Legend Claudia Black longtime Gamers may
have recognized clotho's voice as the
actor has been part of several iconic
franchises interestingly Black's most
famous voice role is arguably that of
Morrigan from bioware's Dragon Age
series Morgan is a witch of the wilds
and one of the main companions in Dragon
Age Origins talk about perfect casting
the actor also has roles in two Mass
Effect games another signature BioWare
franchise black has also voiced roles
for popular titles like Call of Duty
Uncharted and Gears of War and that
barely scratches the surface on top of
her several gaming roles black recently
guest starred in four episodes of HBO's
The Nevers in 2022 she leapt into
another live-action sci-fi project
taking on the leading role of Carla gray
in Deus
aside from voicing countless iconic
video game characters black is probably
best known for her early recurring roles
on Farscape and Stargate SG-1 shows that
are considered absolute gems and Staples
in the Sci-Fi genre
[Music]